[Music]
okay saw three of them today first one
that we saw was secret Life Alert tense
part two was one of those animated ones
what's the name of it uh
that combination its illumination
studios yeah and it was a good movie
there was there was a lot of kids in the
audience man out when they were coming
in there man they were crying and making
all kinds of noise and I was like man
it's gonna be miserable as soon as that
movie started Wow yeah total silence yes
they were just they were just totally
they were just totally renovated by this
and then it was a very simple story
about you know a female dog who's trying
to save a damn little plastic B and a
male dog that's trying to save what was
what was he trying to say he was trying
to save a tiger right or a bunny rabbit
was trying to say that bunny rabbit was
trying to yeah trying to say he thought
he's a superhero he's trying to save a
captured tiger from a circus I forgot
what the with the oh it didn't really
matter you know I mean I kind of even
that was just I think I saw the first
one like a long time ago and it was just
like you know all the pets like what
they do like in the apartments like what
all their owners are gone yeah but this
one was like some of the stuff took
place in the apartment complex but then
some of it was like the main dog Max who
was voiced by Patton Oswalt he's kind of
like neurotic and stuff and hidden the
other dog who I think's name was Duke I
can't repeat did the boys for him but
they get taken out to a farm
yeah they meet another dog who's really
cool named Brewster he's voiced by
Harris before and so like max kind of
learns to be brave and stuff but all the
pets like they had like three or four
different like missions and then in the
end they all kind of come together they
all kind of come together kind of like
it was kind of like an ensemble yeah we
always judge these kind of movies of
course you know where I'm not the
intended target the intended target is
somebody who has to take a kid to a
movie will the kid like the movie and
will the movie drive the adult crazy
that's how I judge these movies and in
this case from what I saw the kids loved
the movie and I was entertained by it so
if you had to go take a kids
it wouldn't drive you crazy and enjoy I
liked the little cats in it - I liked
the character of Chloe and I liked her
trying to teach four you know one at one
of the missions like the Chloe had to
teach a bulldog how to act like a cat so
she had like infiltrate like it was
really the whole thing was nothing but
just a bunch of action and it was
laughing laughs have not laugh a minute
it was a laugh every four five seconds
it was constantly just funny through the
whole thing yeah a lot actually it was
super cute yeah there was like a lot of
really funny like adventure and there
was a lot there was a dolt adult humor
that adults get you know I mean when it
comes to animals and [ __ ] that animals
do you know hey if you have cats you'd
like it yeah
you
okay a second one that we saw was black
men and black International so I saw the
original min and black movies and I
wasn't a really big fan they were just
okay you know they were fun to watch
yeah yeah and I'd have to say that this
one is actually better than I thought it
was gonna be you and me too it's like I
thought it was gonna be okay like just
from the trailer but it was much better
than I was expecting like from the tree
it's not really trolls don't reach oh
yeah the trailer is doesn't really have
much it's deceptive it wasn't deceptive
but the movie was a lot better than the
trailer yeah when I when I saw the
trailer I was getting ready to kind of
have a bunch of cringy kinda kind of
whoa politics and stuff but really
wasn't anything like that just a normal
movie the story was pretty normal it was
about like what you'd get back in the
90s you know I mean this story would
easily translate to something that would
be in the night I mean I didn't get that
from the trailer but I just thought the
trailer you know I thought a couple of
things were like I'm kind of funny but
like not that funny but like actually
the movie ended up being much funnier
than I was expecting and like a lot I
don't know I like the plot of it a lot
more like a lot of that the action
set-pieces were really cool I really
liked Pawnee was my favorite character
well I thought it was gonna be it's
gonna have a lot of like gender identity
politics because murder is one of oh
it's not the minute back it should be
the men and women in black or something
you know I mean I just thought all
they're gonna do like a are they gonna
do like a war between the sexes with
this thing what the hell's going on but
it turned out they just kind of laughed
a lot of that [ __ ] off in the movie the
movie doesn't know that was just a
throwaway line yeah and that's how I
took it in the trailer I wasn't sure and
it's super or not it's like that's not
yeah basically what it's about it's just
like you know a girl that finds them
what she can tell from the trailers and
so she ends up like going on a
probationary mission yeah they go you
know fighting these aliens that can run
like she's in a really shape-shift but
they can like take on someone else's
identity and then they're also they're
supposedly a mole in men and black so
they have to figure out like who
what's going on yeah you know the the
thing about the movie is that I think
the movie was well made I think Steven
Spielberg produced it yeah it was
executive producer it was a well
executed move movie I think the acting
was pretty good the story was okay but
you know it was it's kind of a say
meanness to some of these movies it's
yeah I kind of soon as the movie's over
I instantly forgot a lot of it yeah it's
nice it's not something to me it wasn't
something that really stood out
not a bad movie but just didn't react a
bit like it's one of those ones where
it's like you enjoy it while you're
watching it and it's not yes yeah right
that's the thing with those you watch
him you have a good time when you watch
and when it's over you can't yeah okay
you kind of forget about but yeah I
liked it a lot better than that that I
was expecting it
okay Darwin we saw shaft shaft was a
kind of like a continuation of a 1970s
genre that was offering some kind
sometimes often call it blaxploitation
which is kind of a misnomer because that
was something the media called it really
all really what those movies were was
basically given the black audience in
the 1970s the movies that they wanted to
see and people some people didn't find
that accessible psychotic blaxploitation
but they were just movies cool movies
well they took that and they brought
that into the modern era with shaft
shafts dad and shaft sons there's three
generations of shaft go on a sucking
mission the though the movie I loved it
I loved it I thought it was hilarious
even though it was not a comedy movie it
had a lot of comedy in it it was
actually a detective action-adventure
movie yeah that had a family theme to it
it had a generational themes were like
shaft is very much a man in the 70s and
all the qualities the machismo qualities
of the 70s that's what his strengths
were his son was a millennial who is
like an FBI tech tech guy with even a
field agent
he gets data in data analyst and you
know and he's very suburbanite and you
know and his dad doesn't really approve
so there's a lot of humor with all this
you know and in the end his son Kyle
learns some of the strengths of what it
is to be kind of [ __ ] tough and a man
up and then he also learns from the Sun
a little bit how to apologize and take
responsibility for the [ __ ] he does so
there's a little bit of interplay there
but I put the movie up there with
something kind of like what they do with
the Expendables or the new dawn of the
new Deathwish movies it kind of take an
old idea and make it fresh and just fun
you know it was copper it was its
[ __ ] yeah the humor it's like we saw
opening night like right we were seeing
on Thursday night we saw the 9:45 show
which is the later one I don't know if
the earlier one was more crowded but
there was only three people in the
theater know when I went back there a
little bit more a little bit more of
them came there's more like about 20 in
this one and are the first viewing who I
saw walk out probably about 20 and it
was in one of the smaller theaters I
actually would have liked to have seen
this one in the Dolby theatre yeah this
was very if you like if you like John
wick movies you would like this if you
would like to the Expendables you'd like
it if you buy you know I mean it's that
yeah fun self-aware action yeah like I
said it's I guess it's kind of I don't
know if I want to call it a straight
comedy because like you said it's more a
detective action movie but it's
definitely has like a lot like a comedic
tone yeah pretty much in this movie
[ __ ] in is not PC cuz shaft is just
not pc that that's really the highlight
of the movie because that characters
[ __ ] yeah it's hilarious but yeah very
funny I was I was actually this is the
one I was looking forward to the most
because I've been saying you know we
even see in the previous like yeah that
one stood out to me okay this week oh
yeah yeah alright
[Music]